sitting here with Harrison Ford JJ
Abrams Andy Richter talking about the
new Star Wars movie that I obnoxiously
put my name I didn't even do that by the
way someone else did that but we think
that's gonna be big merchandising guys I
think you should think about it
Harrison I can tell you're thrilled to
be here I'm a hero of yours I am
thrilled to be here
cone man cone man Thank You Man yes I'm
very happy to be here yeah you don't
know this Harrison Harris and I are very
close
off-camera we are yeah we live close
yeah we live very near each other yeah I
come by a lot and I'm asked to leave
everyone's obviously very excited about
this film this is a huge cultural event
Harrison you've tried for years to get
the character of Han Solo killed you
went out of your way to kill Han Solo
get your back for this movie what's
going on well it was a long time ago in
a galaxy far far away
and I thought that the best utility of
the character would be for him to
sacrifice himself to a high ideal and
give a little bottom little gravitas to
the enterprise yeah not that there
wasn't some already but I just wanted in
on that part of it sure and that was at
the third at the at the occasion of
filming the third of the original three
did you want it to be a noble death end
at the time preferably yeah rather than
an accident hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please